[Music]
after calling climate change the biggest
existential threat to national security
the u.s military are they the single
largest institutional source of
greenhouse gas emissions in the world
indeed they are and they are not
reporting their humongous carbon
footprint
well there's a large emissions loophole
in the paris agreement is that the
international climate treats your
climate change that was set up to save
the world yeah that's the one and this
large loophole means that governments
are not obliged to cut their military
emissions sandy makes you think doesn't
it there must be a reason for it let's
face it if a war broke out and
governments are rationing their fuel i
will not be putting my money on the army
that drives solar-powered tanks oh what
is it good for when it comes to the
climate absolutely nothing